let's bring in Jay Bilas Jay I don't
know what your nickname was in college
or high school did you have one as a
player I had one in college call me
Arnold because I got so strong and big
that they started calling me shorten it
all legal right above or as far as you
know yeah I have a new nickname for you
okay the moral compass from you yeah I'm
actually pleased by that or just call me
the mean I did but not anymore like
maybe the compass
you know just short for the compass like
you're you're the one that's you're
you're the voice of reason here how's
that I think most of my I think most of
my friends would shorten that to the
last letter all right Jay and ESPN's
championship week coverage begins this
week jail B in Brooklyn for the ACC
tournament next week calling games if
you were gonna sum up what happened last
week how would you do it leaks from the
FBI investigation that that showed most
of what we have known for a million
years in college sports not just college
basketball but college football that we
have a black market economy because the
players aren't allowed to receive more
than their expenses and you know again I
mean I don't mean to come off as
sounding nonplussed about this whole
thing but the only thing different than
we've had in the past and this is it the
FBI is involved and so we are seeing
this stuff with the imprimatur of the
FBI and and the US Attorney's Office in
the Southern District of New York and
and somehow they are saying that this is
criminal because the schools are somehow
the victims in in this whole this whole
multi-billion dollar enterprise I find
that kind of hard to believe but if you
go back over the years like a Giunta
been paying players forever yeah and
it's been in football and basketball and
schools have been paying players forever
and it's been a football in basketball
so you know it's it's not a surprise
it's just a surprise that the FBI is the
one that that sort of is is putting all
this out there what kind of impact if
any does it have on
March Madness coming up I'm not a ton I
mean and again I'm going to sound really
cynical here but but the one thing I
know for sure is no matter what comes
out we are playing all these games when
they're scheduled to be played and these
contracts will all be fulfilled and all
the checks are going to clear on time
and and Dan like this this is cynical
it's true how many times have we heard
from the n-c-double-a that the wheels of
justice and yet still a turn really
slowly and it's like the United Nations
and it's really to the boys the
tournament's coming up and everybody got
cleared in 24 hours and and man when
they want to do something in a hurry
they can do it so you know all that all
that other stuff about the wheels of
justice starting slowly or nonsense they
don't want anything invested with this
tournament and I'm not suggesting that
they would allow anything illicit to go
on under their nose but but they're
going to do whatever they can to make
sure that the tournament's not effective
I don't blame them for that there's a
billion dollars a year at stake it's
actually way more than a billion dollars
here but the right speeds or at least a
billion and then you've got all the
ancillary rights and the other money
that's changing hands but they're not
messing with this tournament we are
playing all these games no game will be
canceled because this will Shawn Miller
be coaching when we get there I can't
imagine it dan I can't imagine it and
and I'm one that that stuck up for Shawn
when the Emanuel book Richardson thing
came out about one of his assistants
that was taking money from an agent in
order to steer players toward that agent
I imagined that Shawn would have known
about that and I still don't know
whether he knew about it but but being
on a an FBI wiretap discussing
discussing the payment of money to a
player I just can't imagine that he'd
he'd be coaching and you know the player
that was in question DeAndre Hayden
played in the game against Oregon on
Saturday and so so if if Arizona and and
the n-c-double-a think okay well there's
no evidence that and he played you have
to ask yourself well I didn't saw Miller
coach yeah you know if there if there's
innocence there you know look I trust
the reporting of marks Leyva I trust the
reporting of Pete bammel and past forty
who purported wonderfully well on this I
trust all of their reporting
but if if somehow that their reporting
their sources are inaccurate then why
didn't chain Miller coach that that's
that's a key question that I think a lot
of Arizona supporters that are
questioning this are missing and we're
talking to a Jay Bilas the compass ESPN
college basketball analyst I'm just
trying to figure this out every time
that something comes up we always think
oh my gosh this is the tipping point now
all of a sudden there's gonna be a reset
button here it doesn't feel like there's
a reset button here where are we getting
to where everybody's gonna be more
comfortable with the environment of
what's going on behind the scenes in
college athletics yeah that's a good
question dan I think it's a little bit
different this time because we're
looking at issues of these being federal
crimes again I don't think they are but
good luck telling a US Attorney what's
what's a crime and what's not I mean the
theory that they're going under is that
these are federally funded institutions
at over ten thousand dollars and so so
these institutions because NC double-a
rules are being broken these schools are
at risk of playing ineligible players
and having that at risk of having to
disgorge profits and and not being able
to properly marshal their assets that
being the players and the scholarships
it's really an odd theory it's kind of
like a bank defining its customers like
a bank employees defrauding bank
customers and then the bank saying well
we were the ones that were injured
because the SEC came back and hit us
with penalties it's it's a crazy theory
but that's what they're going on
so because the a because we got the FBI
in federal you know federal criminal
activity being an issue I think we will
see we will see some change in this but
the question is like right now there's a
commission in the Condoleezza Rice is
chairing that's been looking into this
and and hearing witness testimony and
the like and they're supposed to make
recommendations in April well I mean we
don't even have our arms totally wrapped
around this and so the n-c-double-a can
do two things in my judgment they can
double down on amateurism and say we're
going to make more rules to make it more
more restrictive or Byzantine whatever
you want to call it and and we're gonna
keep going or they can say we're gonna
fashion our rules to reflect the flat as
the fact that this is a multi-billion
dollar industry is professional and
every way and we're going to take our
players out of harm's way for getting
hit with federal cries because these
fools don't make any sense
you know hockey players and baseball
players college baseball players and
college hockey players are allowed to
have agents
why would basketball football players
not be allowed to have agents you know
that kind of thing and they need that
they need to go in that direction so re
rework the rules to make so make it
reflect the fact that we're in a
professional sports environment this is
not the Little League World Series where
somebody's dad is coaching the team
while he's selling insurance on the side
you know that this is big money sports
and everybody knows it and the fact that
all these players are being paid right
now people say well if we opened it up
and allowed the players if you play it
be the wild wild west no actually it
would be a free market orderly contract
driven system we have the wild wild west
now that that's the way I look at it
explain how this we've gotten to this
point and how you pay a player what was
it like in the 70s or 80s your best
knowledge and then where we are now
because you know their coaches who don't
know if somebody's being paid if an
agent gets to the family right away in
high school or the the player the coach
may not know unless the player you know
tells him but the 80s 90s and where we
are now and how players get paid got
paid it was it was it was different with
the same in ways I mean we joke now
about you know the 70s and 80s were the
good old days of cheating where the
player actually got the money you know
now now it's people who are brokering
the player but in the 70s 60s 70s and
80s it was more booster activity you had
agents involved there were players that
would sell their you know they'd sell
their tickets they wait they would use
tickets to barter for maybe getting a
good deal on a car from a local car
dealer things like that yeah it's tough
all that kind of stuff that went on but
it's kind of it's kind of funny to hear
people talk like you know UCLA and
remember in the 60s and 70s
Sam Gilbert was their big booster that
was that was providing you extra
benefits all the players that's a known
thing in the interplay knew it they just
wouldn't do anything
you know you remember what happened SMU
with football all that stuff went on now
it's warm in the in the agent realm
you've got stuff going on there's some
shoe company involvement but it's not as
I don't think it's as big as some people
think and then there's the AAU circuit
where they're able to funnel money
through a you programs and just like
like money was funneled through
nonprofit churches in the Cam Newton
thing you know the idea that this
doesn't go on in football and I know
hope all people go ahead don't look at
us come on now like if the FBI weren't
involved in basketball would be saying
the same thing with football saying
right now is they'd be saying it's not
as white come on it's not it is of
course a few people keep but it's not
widespread if you got paid and would you
tell me of course not why would anybody
do that it was a little back then it was
a totally different time I mean we all
knew people that there were you knew the
stories to Dan you were in school at the
same time I was so there was a story of
an SEC player that that they had set up
Coke machines for the guy so he had a
key to the company and he would throw an
open the coke all the coke machines and
take all the money and there was all
kinds of stuff going on back then and
and we think those stories now are funny
and some of the some of the old-time
coaches that are out on the speaking
circuit they all talk about that they
all make jokes about it but it's a
different time now and and people aren't
you know like Sean Miller like this
stuff this stuff has been going on
forever and the n-c-double-a knows it
has been going on forever they just
couldn't it's like it's like insider
trading or something like that you know
you know what's going on or mortgage
fraud you know what's going on you don't
know exactly who's doing it and and but
the FBI now is showing us exactly who's
doing it with regard to one agent this
is just Andy Miller
it's just his agency there are a bunch
of other agents out there and and so the
idea that this is is not going on in
football basketball on the like of
course it is of course it is they're too
much money we can't have a multi-billion
dollar industry and say the players can
only have their expenses and expect that
it's going to stop there it's not and
and it would be a pipe dream to pretend
that it
and the n-c-double-a like kind of looks
at this like wait a minute you know this
is this is a pristine thing in and come
on man I mean you guys signed all these
contracts you guys brought all this
money into it you guys signed with a few
companies not the players you did this
you're using the players as billboards
and then you want to say wait a minute
how did this become that where's all
this money grabbing coming from I can't
believe these greedy players want more
than a scholarship it's crazy if I was
offered money in college I would tell
everybody that I was offered money if
you were offered money what do you mean
oh you mean now
yeah that would mean I'm a good player
if I gut like I had to pay money Jay I
didn't get offered money so like I mean
you that's the difference between you
and me dad you got paid and you were
worth it no I didn't know oh you didn't
get me I wish I had okay I don't know I
don't know any good player I don't know
any good player that was strictly
eligible in any era you cannot live by
these rules because it what it does is
it makes normal human behavior illegal
you cannot do it and there's there's no
player that ever played in college that
did not take a free meal that did not
take something that would technically
make that player ineligible now they may
have to pay back a little bit of money
and then contain the eligibility but as
a technical matter I don't know any any
good player that that's strictly
eligible
he's the moral compass the compass for
sure yeah
Jay Jay thank you as always and
hopefully we'll be able to catch up and
actually talk basketball come tournament
time
always a pleasure dad if I'm not
indicted by that Thank You Jay Jay Bilas
ESPN college basketball analyst for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show at
you
[Music]